[Music]
Nicki Minaj seemingly confirms she got a
breast reduction I do feel like a queen
that's the queen of the barbs flaunting
her new look while teasing her upcoming
single with ice spice Barbie world and
I'm bad like the Barbie I'm a doll but I
still Wanna Party pink felt like I'm
ready to bend I'm a tent so I pull in a
can like Jazzy Stacy icky old little
Bobby's
[Music]
and we ain't playing tags if we rewind
nearly a year ago Nikki admitted she
wanted to make a big change you know
what somebody I'm not gonna lie somebody
did tell me to get my boobs taken off
um like one of a female in the industry
and I was like no
and yeah she was right I should have
hurried up and took them off a cup oh
it's a cup season yes
yeah and now seems she went through with
the surgery I mean it's pretty obvious
right Nikki writes in the comment
section of her posts new boobs who this
[Music]
it's one of the best feelings in the
world but Nikki's not the only star
going for a more natural look these days
I'm tired of the look and it's just not
flatter and it's just not what I look
like it like totally changed my face and
I'm just I'm ready to get back to Angela
yeah Blac Chyna real name Angela White
has been documenting her journey back to
square one including dissolving the
filler in her face and undergoing breast
and butt reduction surgery
oh
I mean recovery mode right now and the
best decisions I could have done in a
very long time former Playboy Playmate
Kendra Wilkinson's also living a
different life these days you know uh
boobs were in
for a while
and you know the trend has completely
changed when ET spoke with Kendra and
may she said she's now more focused on
what's in the inside I got my boobs you
know I was like oh my God fit in you
know and then um
now I don't really care so much okay so
where are you at in that journey I
really truly want to focus on my health
my mental health
um I'm not really into impressing boys
anymore sure so things have changed so
we can get these guys off my body right
now
foreign